herzlich willkommen an der
landesverteidigungsakademie ich bin euro
ist irgendwie immer und leute hier das
referat operation aus diesem grunde
möchte ich heute ein paar strategische
und operative aspekte zu gründen krise
beleuchten
ich möchte beginnen mit den prinzipien
strategischen handelns wie sie hier
sehen die klassischen marktinstrumente
eines akteurs das bedeutet diplomatie
wirtschaft militär und information sind
im zusammenwirken zu bringen um
letztendlich strategische ziele zu
erreichen
ich möchte einen blick zurückwerfen auf
das jahr 1989 sie sehen hier an der
karte im klargestellt die nato und in
rot dargestellt in warschauer pakt
schon wir ins jahr 2022 sehen sie hier
die linie der nato osterweiterung
auf einen weiteren klick stelle ich noch
da das gebiet der ukraine sie sehen
anhand dieser darstellung einen großen
gebietsverluste ehemaligen sowjetunion
sie sehen hier die kernaussage aus einer
militärzeitschrift aus den usa die
bereits im dezember aussagen die im
herbst getroffen würden da stellt aus
sicht russlands und zwar die angst vor
einer nato osterweiterung und der
absolute wille
in der ukraine davon abzuhalten teile
der nato zu werden
eine rede putins
vom tag vor dem angriffe auf die ukraine
ich habe hier immer kernaussagen dieses
russischen narratives tage stellt
einerseits dass die ukraine fixer
bestandteil der russischen geschichte
kultur und auch des geistigen raum ist
weiters ein beitritt der ukraine zu
einer natur als eine direkte bedrohung
russlands gesehen wird dass die
russische bevölkerung in der ukraine
bedroht ist sowie eine anerkennung der
beiden gebiete und lohans
und putin beendet seine rede damit dass
er die ukraine die verantwortung für
jegliche weitere blutvergießen gibt
sie sehen hier nochmal dargestellt
anhand der karte in der ukraine diese
russischen kerninteressen einerseits ein
puffer zur nato grenze andererseits die
strategische relevanz des zugangs zum
schwarzen meer
ich möchte nur eingehen auf die
operativen umsetzungsmöglichkeiten
dieser strategischen interessen und
konzentriere mich daher auf den beitrag
des militärs
aus meiner bewunderung hätte es mehrere
möglichkeiten geben eine minimalvariante
das bedeutet die inbesitznahme des
separatisten gebiete inklusive der krim
um somit den zugang zum schwarzen meer
abzusichern
eine weitere variante wäre gewesen eine
mittelmäßige ambition die ost ukraine in
besitz zu nehmen hier hätte sich
angeboten ein manöver mit einem stoß
entlang des nebels trennendes gelände
sowie
wiederum die beiden separatisten gebiete
und die creme
als robusteste variante wäre ein
massiver angriff eine möglichkeit
gewesen nämlich mit einem angriff auf
norden direkt auf die hauptstadt mit
einem zentralen stoß sowie auch mit
einem stoß aus dem süden um die
ukrainischen streitkräfte zu zerschlagen
die hauptschule in besitz zu nehmen die
schwarzmeerküste
zu haben und somit
druck auf die ukraine aussuchen zu
können
diese darstellung sehen sie die aktuelle
lage nach etwa drei wochen kriegsbeginn
wie sie sehen im vergleich russland hat
sich für diese robuste variante
entschieden sie sehen auch das
zusammenwirken durch die pfeile grob
dargestellt der landstreitkräfte
gemeinsam aber auch mit operationen
intensive
hauptsächlich durchgeführt durch
luftstreitkräfte um militärische
einrichtung in der tiefe zu bekämpfen
und somit auch die versorgung der
kämpfenden truppe
ukraine zu behindern was hier ebenfalls
dargestellt ist in gelb diese strikte
linie das ist in etwa die linie in der
der ukrainischen streitkräfte im osten
verteidigen
welche gefahren gibt es derzeit
einerseits durch eine zusammenführung
der stöße aus dem norden zuerst im süden
diese ukrainischen kräften moßner
abzubrennen wie bereits angesprochen
wird ist eine sehr trennenden linie mit
wenigen übergangsmöglichkeiten
und andererseits kiew sowie die anderen
großen städte zu isolieren letztendlich
einzuschließen und in einem
verlustreichen häuserkampf weiter zu
kämpfen
was können wir für folgerungen ziehen
eine folgerung ist auf jeden fall sofern
er in der vitale interessen gefährdet
sind aus dieser sicht aus russland waren
als vitale interessen wird gehandelt
weiters hat sich der wanderer langsam
aufgebaut die eskalation ist aber
blitzartig erfolgt mit beginn des
angriffs ende februar der konventionelle
krieg in europa ist sehr wohl möglich
das hat uns dieses beispiel gezeigt wo
sie ihr zentrum immer wieder in
diskussion war und ich möchte auch
behaupten auch von einer derzeitigen
strategischen vernunft des westens eine
hand an den macht instrumenten
diplomatie wirtschaft aber auch
information ist hier der westen klar
überlegen ich komme mir später nochmal
dazu eine deeskalation das spannungsfeld
zwischen hilferufen der ukraine
humanitäres lädt im spannungsfeld im
gegensatz dazu nicht so offensiv europa
zu agieren
insbesondere militärisch um keine
weitere eskalation an zu wackeln weiters
wechselwirkungen mit der
destabilisierung des balkans wir kennen
die problematik um die abspaltung
tendenzen der letzten jahre der republik
srpska aus bosnien herzegowina und
darüber hinaus die stellung serbiens die
einerseits und andererseits auch sehr
wirtschaftliche an der engen
verflechtungen mit russland haben und
sich jetzt auch sehr neutral gegen wir
verhalten
auf jeden fall ein erwachen europas und
ein
manifestieren der bedeutung der
europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik
ich möchte mit einer abschließenden
bewertung einer sehr kurzen abschließen
nach einem ampelsystem und komme
wiederum zurück auf dieses grundprinzip
strategischen heimat im bereich zu
diplomatie kann man sagen aus russischer
sicht derzeit eine sehr schwierige lage
europa ist mehr denn je und sucht dann
ist eigentlich der masse der welt
isoliert diplomatisch im bereich
information zumindestens in westlichen
medien kann man sagen hat auf jeden fall
die ukraine oberhand und die weltmeinung
ist auf seiten der ukraine im bereich
der wirtschaft kann man nicht braucht
nur noch dazu sagen es hat solche
sanktionen wie sie es derzeit gegen
russland gibt eigentlich noch nie
gegeben und somit komme ich zum militär
sie sehen hier ein farbspiel aus grün
und orange nach dem ampelsystem ich
würde sagen russland hat nach wie vor
die initiative
es wurde aber insbesondere der wille der
ukraine unterschätzt
und das tragen wahrscheinlich auch noch
einige andere faktoren dazu bei ich
komme zur strategischen
interessen umsetzung russlands aus
meiner sicht hat es hier eine vielleicht
übersetzung oder fehleinschätzungen
gegeben was letztendlich dazu führt dass
die letzte option derzeit die
militärisch ist die aus jetziger sicht
doch noch einige zeit dauern wird ich
danke für die aufmerksamkeit